hi everyone welcome to another wolf and
language design review
part of our incremental language
development series
uh and looks like we have several topics
today
okay word frequency data
we have Alan and Francisco and their
team here
um we'd start talking about a few things
related to word frequency data last time
um and so we want to have a checkpoint
on a couple of things the first being
the two grams are at least partially
ready to roll out I don't know Francisco
or Carlos if you have any additional
information I know you said server side
it's there but we still need to kind of
hook it up
is that correct right so so because we
didn't have any design in the working
language side we haven't created yet the
API endpoints for for this data
exactly the same as it was for one grams
my assumption was that you'd basically
have a string that has two words in it
and that would be a two gram but I
didn't know if there's some other need
for markup or
um the second Point talking about text
element indicates that you know we do
have some markup language for handling
like part of speech and other okay but
hold on hold on hold on there's a
normalization question right I mean if
you've gotten I mean to me
it's like you give the two gram and the
most relevant thing is the time series
but the absolute normalization would be
of all two word sequences
in English how common is three Turtles
right
um
we just type in Turtles
of all one word sequences in English how
common are turtles
that make sense
yep that's pretty much what I had
assumed okay
and
you know you should be able to compute
uh you know for example a good example
would be word frequency of three Turtles
versus word frequency of three times
word frequency of turtles
hmm
right and this will be clearly smaller
than the than the product frequency
but I think the rest of that design
should just follow through now if you
give
a three gram for example we should
generate a message just saying we don't
have three grams
am I making sense
right I would assume any n gram greater
than what we can actually process and
then yeah we should say not it's not
available at this time
currently available are there any
technical issues with that Francisco or
right the question was more about the
maybe the the second part of the world
yeah let's get the first part
straightened out are we agreed on what
to do with two grams
no right the question is uh what will
how to handle the cases where we want to
for example
set the part of speech right hold on a
second I just want to know have we
agreed what we're doing with two grams
that was the first step here before we
get on to this section here
that's right same thing we're already
doing right yes yes
okay fine so with with straight we're
clear on that
okay
so now
so we have the mock-up to be able to do
this is that correct
we have the data to be able to generate
this is that correct yes
yeah and we do currently support getting
part of speech variants out of word
frequency data you can okay but we don't
have our word senses obviously here
no this is what we get right in the
future
the very notion of a word sense right is
is you know really we're talking
embedding vectors and things like this
um
I mean what is the real thing that we
get here what we really get
is we get a distribution of embedding
vectors
I believe for every one of these
you know a word is there does that make
sense to people I mean maybe there's no
machine learning book here
nobody I understand what you're talking
about but I mean the the data that we
have access to doesn't have I know for
anything okay
I mean we could look at getting a much
better set of this data from a source
that we can discuss
um
okay the question here is we've got
entities for
we have entities for word sensors
correct
we don't have entities for part of
speech variance is that correct
um
we have this entity the grammatical unit
it's something we have no no no no no no
no no no for the word you mean you mean
like
an entity that represents on its own
green as an adjective yep
no we do that we have we have senses
that we we do have the sense information
and we have we have word and Word Sense
entities that are not yet exposed really
that are still okay mental
um
okay but we have the wood and okay so we
could have a word with part of speech as
an entity
if we wanted to
that's an alternative to this structure
here
which is what is this is this a
grammatical what is this
what what is what is this object here
it's it's right above it's a text
element right with of a string and then
have setting a grammatical unit that
takes an entity I see
which is really funky
I think that we we borrowed this from
uh what's the connection yeah that's the
sentence diagramming stuff right
okay so our choices are this or an
entity
I tend to prefer this because
I think with the entity we may have
words that are non-words
right like if I type in nonsense here
what do I get does it try and give apart
a speech variant
or not or does it punt on that does it
only give the raw word in that case
my question yes thanks I mean I I think
it depends on what's in the data set
right in the engrams data set has some
if you don't understand but assume it's
ASDF we or whatever something that has
no does not appear as a word
then I assume it might
give frequency zero and then none of
these things right well for example if
you try apple with three piece you still
get an answer obviously because there
are misspellings right but if I write a
word with a bunch of random letters
that's long enough there will be no
occurrence in the data set sure yep okay
so what I'm asking is well even with
apple with three p's do you get these
variants or not
yes because you have misspelling with
these variants but in other cases you
don't get any data so if you put up a
word okay in the data
we don't have an element here for
preposition Apple never appears you know
seeming like it's a preposition right
that's right
Apple ever really qualifies as an
adjective but
well it's down by a factor of 100 from
the other uses
okay Apple cheeks
Apple what I don't cheeks
oh okay you know
um
is there an alternative to this I don't
think this is obviously silly I mean
it's at least computably handleable
and I can imagine one day being able to
have other annotation here like for
example
um inflections and so on
because what would the input be for
specifying
I mean I haven't seen I don't know the
output for two grams with part of speech
variances what do we get out of
well how do we make it development in in
text structure
we would say
something like this
and we get that and now what's the input
form of that
it's a nested text element
yeah the growing idea for for handling
these was also having a text element
with a list of text elements
I think that's sensible I don't think
you can have much else
but we wouldn't have any annotation for
the
outer that's correct for the outer thing
we will not have any annotation but the
but like if you wanted to get two grams
data for
three Turtles then
you just take the inner thinner thing
from there
we'd feed that into word frequency data
and we'd expect that to work
well that's a separate issue making sure
that word frequency data can take text
elements that's a good thing to make
sure of
that's what the second example under
text element and word frequency data
shows but
okay but the issue is how do you return
in this case you're returning an
association
but what happens when you have
I think what you have to do is just
break out
all the different cases assuming the
data gives you that
you see what I'm saying so in other
words each thing
it's giving you an outro Association of
text element constructs with every word
tagged with part of speech
is what I'm saying
that seems like the only thing one can
reasonably do
right and it's also the most useful
thing to do
Francisco you understand what I'm saying
yeah I'm trying to figure out
well I was also looking at text element
the problem is that it doesn't support
not having the grammatical units so
maybe that's something we need to
improve in text elements okay fine
well so yeah so that has to be fixed
but do you understand what I was saying
otherwise I mean the the way it would
look is it would be an association
um
of which I I can't imitate it but I mean
uh you know this would be some number
and then it would be text structure of
um
the list of text instructors yes yes
right of
um
of each
obviously this isn't real but the The
annotation here with no sub annotation
and each one is in a text element and
that so we the outer level it would look
like that
yes anything that will be fine yes we
will need to modify text element of it
to support this new annotation and the
name part of speech variance seems okay
to me
any alternatives to that
you don't think so great
all right I think we have a plan here
let's go on
ready to go on
yep yes it's clear yeah
[Music]
so this is something that's come up a
couple of times the idea of using our
word frequency data to create a
waiting system for random words yes
um so we think you know Francisco and
Alan and I discussed this a bit and we
think you know for the basic case of I
want all or at least a reasonable subset
of all words for a given language with
their weights we can basically
pre-compute that and have that be
something exactly all we need to do is
to take the words in Word list and
compute their frequencies according to
word frequency data we don't need to go
spelunking for words that are in word
frequency data that aren't in would yeah
exactly and so we'd basically have that
pre-computed you know we could sort them
if we want
and that's relatively straightforward
there are a couple of design questions
or issues that come up from that one is
if we want to do that for historical
cases as well if we do it's going to be
a lot more complicated no I don't think
so I think we just want frequencies I I
think the idea of you know what would
this look like in 1830 no what when when
old Mr Morse started doing telegrams
what was the word distribution then I
don't think it's that important I think
if you want that you can compute it
yourself that was more or less my stance
on it too but um yep yeah basically if
we have one list we need to generate and
maintain and update relatively
infrequently it's pretty easy if we have
to do it for every subset of dates it's
complicated so look I think there's an
amusing possibility which just occurs to
me being able to have word frequency
data with a number as its first argument
um basically giving the frequencies of
the most common and word yep so that's
the second point is basically is that
something that should be Syntax for word
frequency data or should we have some
sort of word list keyword for it
you know and say get the end most common
words yes I I think would be better to
have that as a different function so so
we can Implement that in the server side
of course the reverse lookup let's say
of frequencies but uh will be better to
have data some different entry point
so to get for example the anything that
has a frequency higher than
X percent for example right
well I think there's two cases there is
I want something that has a frequency
over
you know
10 to the minus 3
and
I want the 200 most frequent words
those are both two different cases and I
think there's an argument to be made but
something like word list or a standalone
function would be slightly better Suited
to marking that up versus
overloading word frequency data okay
let's discuss what we need we need word
list where
it's basically
you know
uh look if we say word list
right now we just say wordless and and
we have common words as a concept in
word list right yes I think what we
should do
is we should say common words and then
maybe something like this
common words comma
well
look you know what we should say
we should just have a thing called
sorted common words
or something like that or
I I think the problem with world is is
that it doesn't include for example
inflected words but the word frequency
does
well we have to put those together we do
we have you can include inflections
with word list right okay so look the
thing we need the output we need is if
we even have this list of words in order
of frequency it would be very useful
[Music]
and I would even argue possibly
possibly possibly that we should Resort
common words or we could say common
words sorted or something like that
as a
um
and we could even have you know
all words sorted
I don't think we want to overload
the frequencies I mean if we say word
frequency data
of
cat
and dog
okay all right we're getting that so
I would have thought what we should do
is just have a number here word
frequency data of 20 gives the
frequencies of the 20 most common words
that's what I'm saying
I suppose word frequency data of all
would be a potential syntax if you
wanted to get
well all is going too far because it's
going to be too big right yeah we should
not support that at all Yeah well yeah
we don't want to just dump this but it
is also the case that you need to Cache
the information on the current frequency
of every word in word list
right so all of those are fast lookups
are making sense
yep
so then it's no big deal that you get
you know the most and most common words
and then you call word frequency data on
that list of common words and then it
gives you the the list right so it's
fine to do it in two steps like that
and if you say I don't see the use case
for you know words more common than
frequency X and I think the number of
words is small enough you just generate
them all and you just do a cut off
do you see what I'm saying yeah so I
think the the sister design question for
this is what the syntax would be in a
random word to say I want a random word
weighted by frequency okay great let's
look at that
because we do have random no no I
understand let's just finish on the word
list okay so obviously common words
sorted we need for all languages Etc et
cetera et cetera that for which we have
word lists what's happened to the
swadesh lists for um
uh uncommon languages are those in now
do I need to ask the question again no
there are a bunch that are in language
data but I don't think that they've all
been added to as additional
languages in word list
too but there's yeah but there's they
there they have been incrementally
cleaned up but nobody has been able to
work on cleaning them up for a while
there's there's more
there's a lot of garbage in the in the
text
okay well in any case
all right so
it's Commonwealth sorted known words
sorted
um
I would assume stop word sorted or
adjective sorted is less useful but if
that's useful but I mean I don't know
whether we should support it
um
the fact that we have that list syntax
means that what we could do is we could
have a general sorted thing so we could
say adjective
sorted
but we could have the shorthand of
common words sorted as a single string
yeah I guess that's yeah then we don't
end up doubling the number of key
keywords
yeah I could get behind that
okay let's look at random word now
I think we should just say weighted
words
or weighted random word weighted comma n
okay
I don't see any an objection to that do
you
no I just I wanted to make sure if we
were using you know if we're talking
about weighted words in two different
functions that we're using common terms
but they are the waiting matters in
random word it doesn't really matter in
word list the order yeah it's really
sorted and I think what we want to do is
and and waiter so we only have a unique
so weighted words means everything
no you could do this as well I think
I think you should be able to do that as
well
I'm saying that's like type and pause
right but what about common words and
known words it doesn't matter because
you're not going to generate the
differences is so far in the tail I mean
yes if you want to do that you say
common words come awaited known words
come awaited
see what I'm saying and just weighted
words is equivalent to
one of those or neither of those
I suspect it's known words weighted okay
but I don't think it's ever going to
matter
because
that should be like not giving any
argument right like random word without
any argument maybe so the equivalent
well right now we've got a pseudo-random
commonly used word that's what we say
yeah common words is the default
and I think that's a good thing to do I
do not think we want to wait them there
the use case and we've got many many
examples it's a it's a thing you know
this is the how well do you know words
in English right you can estimate how
well you know English by doing that as
opposed to the weighted version in which
you know
chronograph will not appear
do you see what I'm saying
unless you're generating really large
sets here yeah yeah it's very unlikely
to occur right this this thing if you
generate 10 weighted words they're going
to be the and a and things like that
most of the time they're unlikely to
break the top 100.
right now an interesting question
yeah that's okay I mean so if you want
to generate a plausible sentence word by
word
actually we got two two points to make
here
if you want to generate a plausible
sentence word by word you do it by
saying random word you know weighted
comma weighted words comma one
or just waited we could just have waited
there
possibly like that kind of like
including words just because we have
common words and known words instead of
common and now I look at but
okay so so then
you know you say random word weighted
words comma one and you just say table
of that
making sense
but you're unlikely to get a sensible
sentence from it you're just yeah right
right right now one thing that happened
that we did for that chat gbt explainer
piece that I wrote
is we actually did work out what the up
to five gram would go up to three gram
four gram I forget
word
uh multi-word
you know probabilities were if you
understand what I'm saying
right and that's why I don't like much
this uh notation of word frequency data
a number because that wouldn't work fine
for example for two grams
so how will be there I have to figure
that out right that's uh
the single word case is much more common
right so for two grams
I mean we can have some notation like
like that number Arrow the graminess
right it depends on how far we're going
to be able to get with different grams
do you see what I'm saying
if we only get to 2 grams that's one
thing if we pre-compute it for three
grams and so on that's another thing
right
right trigrams is kind of very large so
no no no no no no no no not this case of
it not word frequency data when
when it's the most common three grams it
obviously by definition isn't large
do you see what I'm saying oh I see
it's not really filtered yeah it's
obviously not large because it's it's
okay so I had a thing here
okay same problem too
okay so I think this is as far as we
managed to get I think this was a
non-trivial computation
am I making sense
hi guys are you still there yep yep just
please please please make sure you
actually respond if you if nobody
responds I have no idea whether anybody
could even hear what was being said
yep yeah we got it I was just reading
okay
so
the answer is we're not going to be able
to get easily Beyond
you know
I don't think we should worry about two
gram most common two gram
frequencies I think we should just have
word frequency data of a single number
meaning the most common n words
am I making sense
yeah okay I'm going to assume the answer
is yes because if you say nothing it's
just going to be yes people said yes you
need to listen yeah all right okay
all right let's move on anything more on
this topic
okay I think that gives us marching
orders
right these are two function or two sets
of functions that were suggested by chat
GPT which we don't have
um we have alphabets we have writing
scripts we have data about them we don't
actually have the data broken into
vowels and consonants which is actually
I want to say that we have that property
internally in there I know it's never
expose I know that yeah
because it was not very populated but
maybe we can work on that to start
exposing so do we want
a function vowels of English or do we
want alphabet comma vowels
I mean the Notions of valves versus
consonants is complicated what's that I
mean alphabet itself is also complicated
because we include things like
syllabares inside of it that aren't
technically alphabets but
what's property
any property from property is any
property from The Entity value you know
what really pisses me off I'm sorry you
know how many times have we gone through
you can't have something listed here
without giving it giving the information
on what those properties can be here
where do you think where is that being
documented nope you're right it's just
infuriating just infuriating we go
through this you know how difficult is
it to follow that rule
well it's easy when you're writing new
documentation but given that our style
has changed and we have six thousand
Pages you know who who do you who do you
think is that style changed okay
whatever we should fix this please
yep I will make sure that gets done
and then it seems to me that the
reasonable place to put this vowels
thing is that's the second argument
does that make sense I I don't know you
know this notion of vowels is a little
bit complicated in some languages is it
not
right and I think that will be a CCS
exposing the property to to entity value
and Alpha will encourage that okay this
has nothing to do with entity value this
is a function alphabet right it's not
about alphabet uses entity value I don't
care
what matters is what the users will see
which is this function
right and and what you're telling me is
that if I say something like you know
Spanish vowels
is that going to work or is that not
going to work not yet but it's easy to
make it work how come it doesn't work
didn't we go through this like 10 years
ago
what happened
I don't think so I mean we have a
handful of properties that are in Dev in
in like this is coming from language
data right or yeah
that's what that's what that's what
Francisco was saying there are
properties
foreign
it's like a decade or something I don't
think it's a decade okay but let's get
this exposed please
reasonable right objections well I mean
my main concern is that there are plenty
of languages which don't have distinct
valve and consonants right they just
have basic syllables
so I mean
yeah Japanese doesn't have still it
doesn't have vowels all syllables have
an attack so what are we going to do
with those languages what are we going
to do when you say alphabet it's
probably say missing not applicable
right fine that seems fine to me
I mean if you say alphabet of
it okay so for example in Japanese
so this would work Katakana would work
yeah okay and each of those is a
syllable essentially some of them are
Standalone vowels but many of them are
consonant vowel pairs
okay so when you ask for vowels in a
language in which those things are
syllables should you get the vowel only
syllables
thank you
could but then we'd probably for
symmetry would we want to give the
consonant vowel pairs for consonants
you mean is it necessary that the union
of constants and vowels is the whole
alphabet
I don't know I'm sure I don't think
that's true for every language
what do you mean are they necessarily
disjoint
I don't know no I don't know there are
many letters that uh are used as vowels
and as consonants and actually English
is a case yeah yeah I was I was gonna
say right so is y a consonant or a vowel
or both yeah both we have them in both
properties yes okay fine then you've
already answered the question so we pick
up so there are languages where it's
well defined and the things which are in
the consonant list things which are in
the vowel list those May overlap there
may be things that are neither vowels
nor consonants like some of these
languages that have I don't know like
softening letters and things right
that's a different category of letters
right right
which probably have a name so my
question in like the Unicode standard is
there a designation of vowels and
consonants
but there are probably things which make
a sound versus not make a sound I forget
what that's called in phonology
so so there are things that are the are
critics as symbols in Unicode that's
right but
Unicode is about orthography not
phonetics right so yeah yes that's
correct so I don't think it'll have this
sort of information in it right but
something like this right that's a
perfectly valid vowel in languages that
have that correct
well it's some it's somewhat it's
somewhat language dependent in in some
languages right it's a compound
I mean in some languages right it's a
compound
character thing and in others it's
considered a unique letter
that's right yes
uh so what are we going to do with this
is it going to be considered a vowel and
let's say German or something or not
oh I've got to in a form in German I
know a is
uh do you understand what I'm saying
okay in some language that somebody has
spanks
can we discuss that case
pick a case so so you don't you don't
get that as a vowel itself because it's
not in there for example the guy you
know in Spanish we have the the accents
right the accents are not part of the
basic alphabet
right so so that's a letter by itself so
it's not a letter with a Critic okay
fine but if I say alphabet
or German for example
you don't get the umloads it's okay all
right well that's an answer then that's
not a vowel then
what do you get for Hebrew
okay so you get
uh yeah so you get the message
that that's a yud
that's the tenth letter which you know
is roughly corresponds to a y or an e
um so it's not just it's not just a
softening I mean like in I think isn't
it the case that like in Russian
maybe somebody now isn't isn't that
creature there for example just a some
kind of softening thing yeah yes they
they fall from the last yes that's it
okay
right so yeah so you'd you'd can really
it can serve Earth uh orthographic
purposes where it's merely completing
uh uh you know other it's denoting the
end of consonants but it can also form a
a sound which is why I say it's sort of
like the why of Hebrew
okay
so here
you are considering these I don't know
anybody who knows this language but I
mean those are considered separate
letters like the Enya thing in Spanish
is that correct
yeah I guess we can ask Gosha and this
is something we created for foreign
yes I guess we could ask both but I was
actually just talking about uh about the
a with the little thing next to it with
uh with her this week because igevantek
is you know has that letter in her name
uh
it's gonna say for example alphabet
Korean will give you all of the sub
characters that make up consonants but
they're never written independently
you know I don't know if
I I mean some of the letters in Hebrew
are sort of vowel like but the actual
vowels are all diacritics which are not
listed here right
okay so look the basic principle has got
to be if it's in
if it's not an alphabet it's not a we're
not going to consider it a vowel or a
consonant subcase of alphabet because it
wasn't in alphabet to begin with if it
is an alphabet
which for example the aom allowed seems
to be in alphabet for Swedish but not
for German yes
yeah the the German umlaut is equivalent
to just putting in the letter e after
the vowel so a um loud is equivalent to
a e right
and so but in Swedish presumably that's
not the case
but in the case we would then in Swedish
we would say the vowels in Swedish
include ayomlaut for example but in
German we would say the vowels don't
include just include things which are
sub subcases of the alphabet list is
that correct
yeah I think that's consistent right yes
okay
and so then go ahead I I'm just curious
in Hebrew did did we list any anything
for vowels uh since some of the letters
are a little bit vowel like or is that
empty because all the actual vowels are
are diacritics
can somebody answer that I mean I don't
have the data to answer that yeah yeah
that was a question directed at
Francisco if he happened to know uh I
can look it up right now but yeah
[Music]
yeah so please look it up for that
German and polish uh sorry German and
Swedish just to check that we are
somewhat consistent here
okay but so that's that's what
we'll put it in as an alphabet property
and it's also a property in language
data makes sense
okay syllable count
right so this is another chat GPT
suggested function uh we don't have
syllables in word data uh we do have
properties of hyphenation but it isn't
100 correspond and the word data doesn't
include inflected forms
so
we could basically just say well
hyphenation is close enough or we could
have something that you know tries to to
build off intelligent rules and you know
I know there are
you know if I mean the function
syllables which takes a word and Returns
the list of syllables seems like a
possibility
right
just like we have
I mean you know actually the name would
probably be text syllables
just like we have text words
like that
for Hebrew and John we don't have
syllable data we don't have that the
vowel data well we need to create that
from from different sources so yes
but the Swedish it does include all
those diacrific marks yes which are part
of the uh their basic alphabet that's
right here
okay great all right text syllables I
still have a couple more examples I just
emailed you in a separate notebook
because they didn't
end up in this copy of the agenda for
some reason but
um
yeah I think
being able to get the syllables is
helpful uh you know we can have that
based on the hyphenation system that is
in where data
there's various bits of text analysis
that use things like syllable frequency
um
I mean you're sending me this yeah this
is just a subsection here that shows
an application for like grade level
reading analysis
this is the toy function I put together
for syllable count the and the
difference between hyphenation but the
the flesh Kincaid counting system is
basically a way of looking at both word
and syllable frequency inside a text to
effectively associate a reading level
with text arbitrarily
well we have word count yep but I think
it's
isn't it more useful potentially to have
a text syllables that breaks you know
that makes a list of lists where every
word is put in a sub list with with
syllables
yeah I'm trying to think if there's any
other markup structure that makes sense
but I think a list is probably fine for
each individual
word containing the
syllable subsets
then we need to have another property
that's the word broken into syllables
but because what you were saying Nick
what we have is the pronunciation but
then we have that in IPA
there's pronunciation I think there's
also hyphenation I think there's a
property for
um
hyphenation that is broken up basically
into two parts or end parts for n
syllables
what would it do for words that aren't
in the list
what would which do for the the text
syllables
for like nonsense strings or
yeah
hyphenation gives exactly what we're
talking about here
that's the entity property or something
you're saying right yeah right so for
words we don't know about right now
sorry I was just just there was a
property but known words there's a
there's a function repository syllables
thing that Mark Greenberg made that's
heuristic based that seems to do a good
job for English
if you if you want something
um to look at
if I remember correctly it's just a
bunch of replacement roles or patterns
more or less a more decorated version of
the the syllable account version right
here but yeah yeah but it actually
splits instead of just counting instead
of just counting yeah yeah
okay guys so just
I mean do we basically agree that we
want to function like text syllables
yeah I think Bob's point was what do we
do with something that doesn't have
syllables or or we can't parse you know
proper nouns right yeah you got to be
able to handle things new words we've
never seen before
we have to have rules and if we can't do
it we just put the thing as a single
lump right it's not an easy problem yeah
yeah
I mean I have to believe
in the modern world of machine learning
that this is the kind of thing that
should be doable
be a good summer school project actually
okay yeah we can we can always run it by
the ml group too and see if is anything
um
add it to my
list here
um
I don't imagine the new big LMS will be
helpful since tokens are
yeah that's a little messy story The
Tokens there right but there might be
other models
right I'm sure you can just train it
from knowing you know from knowing how a
lot of words are broken up into
syllables right you could use a basic
classifier probably
yeah
um and it may not know for sure I mean
you know there are people there are
names where
you know you just don't know how it's
pronounced until you hear the person say
it
right
okay
let's continue
so uh following our discussion last time
Danny went ahead and implemented
digitsum uh based on the spec we have
Ian Danny and I looked at it a little
bit along with some other people there's
a futurized ref page we can look at and
then there are a couple of design
questions that come about from that
[Music]
um
I think this is fine the third argument
is kind of amusing
what is digital root
uh so there's a link there but it is
basically the
leading value on a digit sum
what do you mean by that
so it's the highest order digit from a
digit sum regardless of the base
who cares
I thought it was the point of Digit sum
sorry what was that again I thought that
it was the fixed point of Digit sum
that probably makes more sense it's like
casting out nines
yeah it's a general case of yeah casting
sounds like a lovely wfr okay
yeah I'd seen it come up associated with
digitsum fairly frequently so I figured
it was worth it I think our former
content guy Christopher already put it
in the first repository if I remember
quickly
should digits some support mixed Radix
I I don't know that seems awfully
obscure
what about you know Fibonacci based and
stuff like that I mean it just seems
awfully obscure
does that
well we support I mean the argument and
favor is that we support it in things
like uh you know integer digits and so
why not support it if it's easier to
support let's support it
is it easy I guess we we do integer
digits in the
mixed Radix and then yeah some of them
okay
these are last couple things in case we
had a little bit of extra time just some
more miscellaneous GPT suggested
functions that
are reasonable to implement
um I think power range is pretty silly
yeah I it seems pretty trivial I mean
and I'm not even sure
it's the right thing I mean I think it
will be more like I give you two primes
or I give you two numbers
right and I guess this is going to give
you two numbers and you give me primes
between them
right I mean isn't this just Prime of NN
right or or some such
no it isn't Primal venom look look it's
it's the value
it's like I guess that's definitely I
guess that definition is yes just doing
the sword but uh one might have expected
just from the name Prime range to to it
to be
well whatever but I think it's
what does this the what does this do
that is
okay
what
the other way around
I think I think you need a large
secondary
just use two to one thousand or
something like that
right so it's going up by powers of ten
or I can say go up by positive 2. yep
okay
let me put Prime range in the function
repository at least that doesn't strike
me as
I'm missing something it doesn't seem
like the kind of thing
so this is an operation which could be
useful but I think it needs a
generalization it's a bit like an
interpolator
we could have two points and then we say
diffraction of the distance from the
first for example
well what is that for an ordinary line
I mean
there is this concept of lerp
l-e-r-p and and and it's spherical
version
so this is a linear interpolator
and there is this standard name and and
then there is the s l Erp slurp
for the spherical version you give two
points and it gives like 0.4
of the distance to the first we have a
function that does this but I've now
forgotten its name which is a really bad
sign
um Blend or yeah but it's like blend but
it isn't planned
so blend does it for colors but I don't
know the general
I mean this is a very useful function to
be able to get
um
maybe we don't have it I mean
rescale is similar
it's similar but isn't the same thing
yeah
look I've wanted this function a zillion
times where you where you go I've got
one point I've got another point
okay
I want to go a fraction
you know X of the way from one point to
the other
I've never heard the term look
maybe I'm just out of date
um
um it seems to be mostly related to the
structure produced by larvae of
solid insects
so I I added there Wikipedia page four
for this spherical version
okay
this does seem like a useful function
look even in this linear case this is
definitely useful I mean it's it's
obviously easy to do it's x times the
first thing plus one minus x times the
second thing
right
that's the definition right
yes
but the spherical case is probably not
so easy
is that true it is it is relatively easy
you just need the angle between the two
points
well it's easy depending on what input
you're given
what do you mean
you're given two Theta Phi values right
yep right
and there are separate Geo slurp and
spherical slope then
um
your direction
well no it's not your direction no no
it's it's more like a de-inter plate
like a geoposition interpolate or
something like that
like Geo intermediate given points P1
and P2
I don't really like the name Joe and
tablet because
that suggests we're dealing with
interpolation true interpolation which
is more like you know makeup make a line
from one to the other
I mean I could imagine
and it's it's basically this is that
correct
yes
I'm not sure whether perhaps we would
want
a list
points in the first argument rather than
to separate I'm not sure I don't think
so because I think I mean how do we
specify the x value
as a second argument yeah I know that
but it's not a single x value there's
seven points there what do we what do we
compute
yes no I I wasn't saying a list of
arbitrary length let me just saying that
the pair
it says the first two arguments look too
similar and too different from the
second from the Third
oh I see you're just suggesting
that it look like this
right
possibly yes
question what other functions have done
I don't disagree that's probably right
the other function we we have which is
similar to your destination your
destination
might
take the X somewhere
I understand that your destination
that's not right but this is
just a destination would take the first
point and say move such distance
um
to the second point to the second yes
so perhaps there is a way of indicating
well sorry look at this this has
multiple this
would suggest another syntax which is X1
X2 here right you give multiple
intermediate points yep
I don't think we should try and merge
this together because I think that this
one
although the X I could be greater than
one true or not true yes one can
extrapolate certainly
or even negative
well maybe they should be combined
uh
but D is an actual distance here it's
not a fractional
right right
so I don't think that that doesn't seem
promising
so I I was suggesting that perhaps there
is an extension that you can indicate to
your destination that you want a
fraction of the operation that it
currently does
yeah but look what about the question of
I'm going from A to B but I only want to
go 100 miles along that path
right yeah that's another possibility
I mean it kind of makes it seem like we
want a symbolic thing that represents a
path which we've talked about before a
geopath type thing
and then we want to be able to take the
geopath
and say
we want an intermediate point or a
you know
a geopath point so to speak
right I mean that question exists
already in other Primitives like we have
a spline curve how do I get a some sort
of fractional point of us playing
yes that's a good question
well
uh yeah these are that's a good question
I mean let's look at take a look at that
is not very good Auto completion there
oh God
so the question is what do you how do
you get a point some distance along a
bezier curve right
how do you get a point some distance
along any curve
I mean we can define a curve
just with sort of implicit computational
geometry stuff
um
I think this is an interesting general
question
right and I think we need something
it's almost like given a symbolic thing
like this bezier function
well wait a minute what's this this is
finding a point on the Curve
I don't know what that parametrization
means
I think this is this requires more
research
all right we should probably wrap up
here but let's bring this back this is a
good thing let's try and understand this
okay yeah
all right uh wrap up for now here
um
okay anything else
nope okay should be good see you later
thanks guys bye